what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you know like i'm someone and this is
just where i come from where it's like
i feel like i donate to gofundmes
any time i see a homeless person i not
only offer the money i offer them
food and water so why am i not allowed
to then yell racial slurs at non-whites
in the street
because ask me that because i don't know
why
chris because it's like because you
[ __ ] can't
i don't understand why it works you
can't do nice things for people
just so you can be a vocal racist but
i'm giving homeless people [ __ ] full
bagels toasted with butter
i know dude but you can't have earned it
though
guys you're missing a [ __ ] point he's
clearly doing this so he can exercise
his right to be a complete
son of a [ __ ] yeah i can't i can't
throw a mask at a nation person say put
this on you coronavirus [ __ ]
no you can't i gave a guy if i gave
literally gave a homeless guy a dollar
yeah if i gave a homeless guy a [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] you're racist you're
buying a race i can't call this guy a
dollar i can't go on the subway and go
up to some woman selling churros and say
passport now i call ice in five seconds
you can't find that why not because
you're so offensive to my i'm i'm rather
well take a black guy in the face say
here's your [ __ ] money
hey give a guy if i give a guy
five dollars a week before that homeless
guy you can't buy
your right to be a racist you sometimes
dude
oh it's women's history month let me
tuck it back i've stolen your stories
before you know that
please take anything on the show listen
i told the story on behalf of you i said
it was your story yeah whatever were
your dog
your dog got injected with electrolytes
oh my god yeah how crazy was that that
was you that was him that was him
it was so weird yeah my they where i had
my dog was dying
my mother's dog larry r.i.p larry um
he's in uh he's in dark part of heaven
right now okay dog part of heaven and he
um he was a gay dog
whatever dude even my mother and me was
like yeah is it gay yeah when it's fine
it's great
it's beautiful yeah yeah we were going
to put him down you know we went to go
put him down my mother's you know to
cry you know crying so upset and the
doctor the vet comes in
and she's like you know we're going to
give him a procedure right now he's
going to be
gone in about 10 seconds we just
injected into his pawn he's going to be
gone
and um you know it's we all feel over
soon and my dog's just like blinking
like looking at me and my mom and i'm
just rubbing my mom's back i'm just like
mom it's going to be okay and she says
oh bye larry you know holding his ball
and then like 10 seconds go by
20 seconds 30 seconds larry's just like
blinking
looking at us and she's like and then
the
the the doctor the vet's like sometimes
this happens let me just up the dose
here or just
and then she goes and she puts some more
in and then like larry's just like
looking
looking at it's like a minute two
minutes my mom's like what's happening
why is he getting any more pain she's
like i've got it she's already painting
my mom it's all gonna be over soon
so i'm gonna go over soon so then the
doctor she's like i'll be right back
so she comes back in she goes i am so
sorry about that she goes i did go ahead
and give your dog electrolytes
um she's like you may see a short burst
in energy but that doesn't mean anything
he will
he is dying so
so she's like let me just go ahead so
now my dog is
wrapped up he's like a young pup it's
like running around
and my mom's like but i don't understand
whatever and then she's like i promise
you
i just made a certain mistake i just
started working here it's fine let me
give him this she was like you know he
is dying and then they gave him the
thing and then he died
you know and then he died you know
whatever 10 seconds later but the dog
next to them was the one who needed the
electrolytes and i was like
did you kill the dog next door because i
never thought about that
i'm like could you imagine you killed
the dog next door but whatever dude
i was with great opie from the opium
anthony show and um
sherrod had given opie edibles in a
chocolate bar
right and i didn't i had never taken
edibles before i'm not a drug guy i
don't know
opie just gives me the chocolate bar i
know you're supposed to take half of a
half of the square
of the chocolate bar of course okay so
oh i'm and i love sweets i mean i got
high color you know my collection was
250 up there you have sweet tea
so i love sweets you know so i
literally oh we're on the train going to
the islanders game new york islanders
game
and uh opie just gives me the chocolate
bar and just starts looking at his phone
so i didn't know you're supposed to take
half of half a square i ate the entire
chocolate bar
just to the head sherrod smalls
chocolate
oh my god okay i forget that it even
happened
because ob just for alpe was like not
doing the weed so hoping
he just gave me the chalk bar didn't
even think about it i just [ __ ]
crushed this thing right
having a good time all of a sudden we're
at the islanders game
first period buzzer goes off i thought
somebody threw a spear
from the top of the jumbotron through my
right through the right side of my head
cutting off the left side of my body i
pop up out of the seat i go i'm having a
stroke
i'm having a stroke so i'm yelling and
i'm having a stroke
right i forgot that i was even on
edibles i'm convinced i'm having a
[ __ ] stroke
yeah so i go up the stairs and i'm just
walking around i'm like i'm having a
stroke
i'm having a stroke he's like you're not
having stroke i'm like dude i'm having a
[ __ ] stroke
i'm at the left side of my arm it
doesn't work and i'm like flinging my
arm and it's not working
so then i'm like i have to go so
terrifying
dude so i'm in a packed islanders game
and this is
new york city i'm a big islanders fan
opie's a big islanders fan so people
know
who we are of course they know opie and
they're like so they'll stop ethiopia
they're like oh they that guy's always
on the show
so they're talking to me and i'm trying
to have these dude the actual
just as luck would have it the islanders
broadcast team
interviewed opie and brought me on the
interview oh yeah and i cursed on
[ __ ] sny
what did you say i yelled [ __ ] the
rangers because they were playing the
rangers
so they're like you know camera down see
ya you know
so i literally i had gotten tickets i
had gotten tickets from the islanders
the ticket connect was mine
from the island so they found out that i
yelled [ __ ] the rangers lose the tickets
i leave i leave barclay center
i walk up to a police officer who's in
full swat riot gear because i mean it's
new york city
these guys have real jobs to do this
terrorist activity i woke up to him
i said officer i'm going to be 100
percent honest with you that i with
right now
i've ingested drugs and he goes up and
he goes
and he goes what do you mean he goes up
i said i'm having a stroke
and he goes and he goes okay what kind
of drugs did you ingest
i said i i can't tell you the type of
marijuana strain that i've ingested
but i haven't consumed an illegal amount
of drugs i was trying to use all these
professional words
dude he started laughing at me so hard i
thought he was going to shoot his gun in
the air
so he goes i swear to god he goes kid
get the [ __ ] out of here
that's what he says to me like in a
movie and i was like you know so he goes
get the [ __ ] out of here so i get in a
cab it's on 4th avenue and 8th street
i get in the cab i'm like take me to
where i live 4th avenue and 93rd street
so the by the way it was so i it was
freezing it was january but i had my
jackpot i was so [ __ ] hot i asked
this cab driver to open up all the
windows
this guy opened up all the windows and
he was like shivering and freezing i was
like guy
i'm sorry i'm having a [ __ ] stroke
right now i'm on drugs you got to keep
these windows down and he was like i'm
so cold
i'm so cold i was like if you could show
me a value us passport i'll put the
windows up
obviously he's a cab driver he said
they're staying down
[Laughter]
literally dude it's fourth to stream the
cab driver stopped at a light at 4th
avenue and 63rd street i look at him
like i'm home
i open the door i open the door and he's
like i thought i was on 93rd street but
the six and uh
nine were you know reversed in my head
bro i'm [ __ ] sweating it's like eight
degrees out i throw my jacket
like a four hundred dollar north face
jacket in a public garbage can in new
york city
back right in sunset park brooklyn i
start sprinting home i don't know what
the [ __ ] is happening
i didn't live with my kid's mom at the
time i go to my kid's mom's house it's
10 o'clock at night i ring the bell
dude i ring the bell she goes what are
you doing here i was like i'm having a
stroke
and she was like chris you're not having
a stroke i said i'm having stroke i've
ingested
i've ingested drugs so she goes oh my
god she goes all right come in
so she goes you have to take a shower
she knew she used to use drugs when she
was a kid she's like you have to take a
shower
she's like that's a health shower and
drink milk i know she goes take a shower
and drink
if you had xc and stuff yeah so i take a
shower
i take a shower yeah i [ __ ] start
drinking this milk and then i take a
shower
i take a shower with my shoes and socks
on so that means i got completely butt
naked and i put my socks and my shoes
back on i step in her shower i haven't
heard this story
i haven't heard like like like a black
guy who does porn exactly
exactly yeah exactly how to get the grip
yeah got to get the grip
totally taking a shower with my [ __ ]
shoes and socks on
and then it's like i'm literally it's
getting bad and then out of nowhere just
bang i start hysterical laughing just
hysterical laughing having the [ __ ]
best time and then it was going back in
waves hysterical laughing
terrified historical laughing terrified
i slept on the floor
in my at that time two-year-old
daughter's room
all true i sleep on the floor with her
her she's got a stuffed animal piggy she
[ __ ] loves this animal piggy
i at some point in the night i take
piggy off her bed sleeping on the floor
i wake up
piggy's mouth on my taint yes
literally and i was sleeping but i slept
naked on my daughter my two-year-old
daughter's bedroom farm sleeping butt
[ __ ] so think about
what she has to wake up to yeah two
years old her father who doesn't live in
the house anymore is naked with her
favorite stuffed animal eating her
between my balls and [ __ ] and then i
woke up you know my kid's mom like woke
me up
and she saw what was happening because
she was the one who woke me up she was
like chris
get out and then and then like i should
use the whole thing and she's like this
is why we can't be together i was going
to say
that's the worst dude dude edibles man
so richard lewis i'm opening for oh yeah
yeah it was an opening for richard lewis
and the first two shows go good and then
saturday it was at eight o'clock it was
a seven o'clock and a nine o'clock show
and it was like clockwork on friday and
the first show saturday like clockwork i
do 10 minutes
get the light that means bring richard
up in 15 seconds just even if you're in
the middle of a joke just stop and be
like
ladies and gentlemen are we here for
richard lewis shalom shalom shalom
boom
so there's a chair being passed around
in the audience yeah so i do my clothes
i
i you know i saturday night show the
late show starts to you know kick off
i'm doing the things and i had a time
like i do my closure about you know
eight minutes
you know start you know ramp it down so
i do my closure thinking the light's
going to come on at the same moment it's
coming the last three shows
and you know i'm looking for the light
and i'm doing the closer
and do the closer no light no light at
all
so i like look over and i'm like okay so
panic i'm like okay so i look and then i
see the owner in the back lewis veranda
great you know
the book legendary booker of uh
caroline's comic club going like this
mean like keep it going keep going and
i'm stretch i'm like
yikes yeah yikes so again i have 13
minutes i've just done 10 minutes
with my closure like the best joke i
thought i had i closed with
it's done so now i'm like okay let me i
worked on something on the train right
over here
let me try this so i do it it's like
yeah you know kind of bombing whatever
but you know when you're a new comic
like you think like if you just get a
chuck you're like okay
right so but you know it's i'm bombing
probably every probably the entire set
was a bomb
you know but i didn't but this was even
worse of a bomb bad this was nuclear
this is nuclear
sold out show saturday night middle of
times square so now
like 15 minutes have went by and i'm
like oh my god what's [ __ ] happening
dude so then i start to go into the
crowd a little bit
and start to ask right people i'm like
hey where are you from
you know what do you do what do you do
birthday is that a birthday
and everything and yeah and everything
like that somebody would say because
again i'm just so new i'd be like ah you
[ __ ] jerk off like you know i was
just doing that and they were like what
this guy's in a wheelchair but you kiss
your brother
yeah yeah he's paralyzed oh no yeah he
was like he just lost his legs in iraq
i'm like yeah you're fargo
you know just bombing and now it's
trying to get bad
dude 55 minutes
impossible how did you do 55 minutes i'm
gonna tell you exactly what i started to
do
dude it got so bad about 30 minutes in
the staff stopped what they were doing
and were dying laughing in the back
because of the [ __ ]
not because of any of my material of
course just because of how bad i was
bombing dude i brought two people up and
let them try a joke
i brought two people on stage and i let
them try like anybody out here everybody
do stand up
two people came up like i'll give it a
shot get a joke one guy actually crushed
yeah he's
killing him yeah it's a bit they start
booking him they're like chris you're
done dude then i
asked i dude andrew i swear to god if
there were 400 people in there i
probably asked 300 people
what uh where they were from uh and and
how many birthdays i asked
are there birthdays in here like 10
times and people like no we said the
birthdays
then dude i started i got to the point
like 40 minutes in
where i started just saying hey guys
yell out of state and i'll name the
capital
and they would just yell out of state
you know they would be like they would
be like iowa i'd be like des moines
that's easy next
like i was just trying to do it they
were like california i was like
sacramento
you know like they're like people i was
like i bet you can't get me like i
wasn't
like it was people coming to play tags
yeah it was
crazy [ __ ] dude 55 minutes in i finally
get the [ __ ] light i
finally get the light richard lewis
comes onto stage
doesn't even address anything he goes
give it up for jeff
and i was just like yes as i'm walking
off he goes give it up for jeff
first of all that is straight up how
they make pink eye
okay that is where it's made my pink guy
the other day was [ __ ] wild and i had
a big
stye in my eye yeah it was from farting
on my phone oh
oh yeah oh my god that [ __ ] was wet
right
yo my fans call me chrissy well farts do
they really because my [ __ ] sound like
they're in a well underwater ass crack
yeah
i got a deep deep deep [ __ ] man
that's what it is really yeah
i had to get a colonoscopy oh wow yeah
the doctor because he i was telling him
like
i played some audio on my farts and i
sent him pick some pictures of my shits
in the office and he was like we need to
take a look
and when they went in there he said take
a look he said it was all good gary
nasser was it that [ __ ]
gymnastics larry nassar larry nash he
said we got to take he said we got to
take a look and then he told me he said
everything's fine but he's
you know in clinical terms said i have a
very deep deep rectum oh wow so he said
that's what's causing the sounds of the
farts
pretty cool rectum damn near killed him
that's chris farley um
did he say that line recognition killed
him sounds familiar um
nick's sister does uh colonoscopies oh
she's a gi doctor
uh no she's she's not just running
freelance bro oh
wow she's not called ask me uh colonics
oh colonics yeah that cleans your whole
[ __ ] out you can pretty much just come
off the street
yeah yeah i mean basically the van will
pull up yeah you know
you ever done one of those you ever got
your [ __ ] cleaned out like that no dude
i'll let god do what he needs to do
inside of my body right
well i'm living biblically since you've
been at the successful have you been out
with the theaters and all that have you
taken a hot
fat [ __ ] bomb yet like a hot like a
real
fat one like just a nice sero in front
of
you know 1500 plus just a real stinker
because it happens man well you just
take a full see it all
somebody goes that's a no-no and it's
just you're just eating it
and you start going where you from oh
you stop going
yo you know what's weird there's nothing
funnier there's nothing
the only things that can make comedians
belly belly belly laugh
is watching another good comedian bomb
and a fart joke
or a fart or just not even a fart joke
just an actual just a wet
nasty [ __ ] rip your [ __ ] third
gear fart like that guy on barstool you
see that guy on barstool with the third
gear fart uh-uh yes
something to look up what [ __ ] do you
think that farts are get nastier in
certain countries or not
i think yeah well i think that's why i
think we need a wall
is because i think you know outside the
united states
those farts man that's the reason i
every time trump's like we need a wall
i'm like yeah mexican's [ __ ] are
dirty
we get that and canadian assets too man
don't sleep on canadian uh
don't sleep on how disgusting canadian
fart could be
poutine you know what that's like that's
cheese curd yeah i want to wall around
all that because
there's a wall around us man well why
don't everybody should just get a little
wall that they can bring with them
and put wherever they want canada and
mexico because the truth of the
situation here we got a man right here
doing something
right here this is the ain't never hear
a fart hit third gear as the couch okay
take a look
and they're gonna blame it somehow on
white people i'm sure dude that's
insane right wow
tokyo drift huh dude i was watching that
thing
for an hour yesterday crying my
beautiful four-year-old daughter was
doing ballet
and doing some of the finest moves she's
ever done and get into new heights in
her life and i was head buried in the
phone crying laughing
because of this dude's third gear fart
and her mom was like this is why we
can't be together
her mom was just she was like
because i was just like yo crying she
thought i was crying first my kid's mom
thought i was crying because how
beautiful
my daughter nailed the pirouette i was
listening to that my headphones on
you know
are they husband and wife yes
you